paris la fin vous avez suivi ce cortège
parti de la place de la madeleine
cortège et manifestation interdite par
la préfecture mais les manifestants
étaient tout de même dans la rue oui
effectivement ils se sont rassemblés aux
alentours de 15 heures sur la place de
la république
plus de 5000 personnes qui étaient
venues défendre les droits des
sans-papiers à la peine vous l'avez dit
de plusieurs collectif de syndicats et
même des gilet jaune alors parmi les
manifestants on a surtout vu des sans
papiers qui sont venus demander
plusieurs choses à savoir des tests
systématiques dans les foyers de
migrants la distribution de masques de
gel ou encore de gand la mise en
isolement systématique des personnes
infectées ou tout simplement et ça c'est
la revendication la plus les importants
qui est le plus revenu c'est la
régularisation des sans-papiers à qui
nous avons tendu notre micro
je propose ne les écoutez pas mal bd des
marges étant ici qui sont des
travailleurs sans papiers et à partir du
moment que cette pandémie est venu y
sont restés à côté ils sont pas payés
nous quoi ils sont dans le foyer et où
ils n'ont pas de ressources
de quoi vivre et où est ben voilà ils
sont restés bloquer totalement que ce
soit à vivre ou quoi que ce soit
côté santé et côté bas ils sont restés à
côté valve a oublié même je vais dire si
le mot mais permettent
bon voilà donc cette fausse alors on est
venu aujourd'hui pour montrer notre
colère pour montrer aux français au à
l'état français
donc en fait de nous régulariser notre
hobbit séquelles des mourides
régularisés et voilà et en fait on est
dans des bains 0 un moment de solidarité
voilà qu'elle s'attend à vivre que sa
foi voilà autres ben voilà on est là
pour manifester montrer au peuple
français
tournée de leur poule et m'oblige est
aujourd'hui pour
notre situation malheureusement nous
sommes là bon dans ces deux pays la
france qu'on ne peut dire donc vous vois
tu ce moment-là que mobiliser pour la
grèce et pour notre régularisation
parce qu'on vit en france depuis des
années il y en a qui vit ici pendant 10
ans ou 20 ans sans papiers s'arrêter
tous et surtout des on peut dire des
sanitaires tout ça donc nous sommes
quand même dans une situation vraiment
très très difficile
toutes les personnes qui sort là on est
là à poser le papier on n'est pas là que
pour thiers quelqu'un on n'est pas un
voleur
on n'est pas pour gaspé de quelque chose
inversement le papier pour travailler
quand même tu sais on a travaillé
beaucoup de pays on a on apprenait des
bases et des talus espagne beaucoup les
payes pour génération
vous l'avez entendu des sans papiers qui
ont l'impression d'avoir été
particulièrement fragilisé par cette
crise du coronavirus alors la
manifestation a duré une heure sur la
place de la république dans une ambiance
on va dire festive plutôt calme et puis
très vite les forces de l'ordre ont
demandé à la foule de se disperser
puisque comme vous l'avez dit cette
manifestation a été interdite par la
préfecture de police alors des gaz
lacrymogènes ont été tirés à plusieurs
reprises le cortège s'est dirigé au
niveau de l'avenue de la république où
les forces de l'ordre
on a c'est absolument tout le monde
c'était très difficile pour nous un
journaliste présent ici de filmer ce qui
se passait on a quand même assisté à des
arrestations à ses muscles et on a vu
deux cars de police remplies de
manifestants qui reconnaît aux vitres
pour nous interpeller et
systématiquement que nos équipes ont
essayé de filmer ça a été très dur très
dur de travailler aujourd'hui et
finalement ça a été aussi durs pour les
journalistes de couvrir cette
manifestation que pour les manifestants
de de tenir cette mobilisation donc la
manifestation est maintenant terminée
ici sur la place de la république mais
les organisateurs appellent à un nouveau
rendez vous le 20 juin prochain
merci beaucoup lit la fa pour toutes ces
précisions il